this man's identity is unknown he was
believed to be between 30 and 40 years
old he wore a white hood and was known
only as the phantom killer there's no
time 13 o clock well hey everybody it's
a rainy Saturday afternoon we're sitting
here with our special orange juice is a
special orange juice yes it is yes it is
special
aside from vitamin C yeah and we are
recording episode 95 another one of our
popular true crime extravaganzas yeah
which one is this we're actually doing
the Phantom killer the Phantom killer
yeah it was remind me which one was that
very famous uncaught serial killer from
the 1940s hmm wore a bag over his head
with the I shot couples and lovers lanes
they made the movie about it the town
that dreaded sundown okay yes they never
did catch that guy and Rambam killer yes
although that was just in the movie
though yeah and I'll get into that a
little bit actually the movie that was
made that Charles B Pierce made wasn't
that inaccurate I mean they changed all
the names of the victims obviously but
other than that the details were mostly
accurate there were a few places where
you know yes the trombone thing where it
kind of went off the rails a little bit
but in general it was fairly accurate to
what really and just off the top of my
head I think they actually had a couple
suspects isolated hey Jess yes oh you
did yeah so we'll get to that
yeah now the first thing I want to do
got kind of a lot of shoutouts or things
I wanted to point out at the beginning
of the show our latest movie review was
tourist trap from 1979 people seem to
like it which yeah that like I said on
the show it's like it had been requested
a bunch of times it was on the list yeah
we just hadn't gotten to it yet and like
somebody kept going hey
you gonna do tourist trip what are you
gonna do I'm gonna get that on blu-ray
so finally I was like okay we'll do it
we'll do it I'm gonna get that one on
blu-ray that one was pretty good I wanna
yeah yeah cuz I really do like that
movie there's more to it I didn't pick
up everything about them you know I mean
I think there was some stuff in there
that I hate yeah and I would like I said
on the show I think I would like it
better if I saw it so visually it looked
wrong because you know we just saw the
crappy Ephs there's probably more in
there whether or not he was doing that
with psychokinesis or if you know or if
spirits were actually inside those
mannequins yeah yeah probably yeah
there's probably something I'll probably
figure them out and speaking of movies
if you guys listen to my solar review of
Suspiria where I decried the fact that
they were going to make a remake of it I
actually saw the trailer for the remake
and it looks pretty [ __ ] good and
this is very very hard for me to admit
because I love Suspiria some of my
favorite movies ever now you said it
didn't have the colors though right and
also I should note that I've been
hearing because I guess I don't know if
they just showed like a scene from it or
if they showed the entire thing at a
horror convention from the scuttlebutt
that's coming out of this convention
people are saying that it is fantastic
and that it's like super super super
gory but also really really scary really
eerie well there'll be a theatrical
release work yeah it should be I think
it's coming out this fall I don't know I
mean exactly just says fall 2018 so
actually as curmudgeonly as I was about
it on the review I actually have to
admit that it looks pretty good and I
think I said this on my superior review
but I was like oh well if you remake
Suspiria without all the primary colors
and the crazy visuals then it's not
really Suspiria but it looks like they
did get an Italian director to do it and
it looks like he went in the totally
opposite direction he made it look very
70s period but it's he used a very drab
color scheme and now that I'm seeing
that I'm like that was the right
decision up yeah you think because I
think that if you had gone in the whole
I'm gonna make it look like Dario's I'm
right it looked like primary crazy
primary colors I think you would have
left yourself open to accusations that
you were just ripping off the original
and why bother so
looks like he's trying to do his own
thing with it while keeping true to the
spirit of the original which is all you
can do really if you know if it has to
be remade but I will reserve judgment
until I see it but I'm gonna say it
actually does look really good and I
never thought I would say that okay so
this fall we're gonna go see it all
right all right and the only other
things I wanted to shout out remember to
go to our Zazzle stores as a lock-on
slash 13 o'clock podcast is it just 13
o'clock podcast or just 13 o'clock I
can't remember but it's one of those two
things and we have shirts on a tote bag
also check out our patreon account and
our blog at 13 o'clock podcast wordpress
com if you would like to give us a
PayPal donation which someone named Greg
did this past week yeah we actually
recorded the show before he gave us the
donation like the day after we recorded
the show even though several days before
we put it up so I didn't get to put him
on the last episode thank cities on this
one so thank you very much Greg also
we've had some other fans like do some
other stuff for us our fan duncan
actually started a subreddit for the 13
o'clock podcast okay he made me a
moderator over there or he invited me to
become a moderator and he has so far ID
he's put up like the first it looked
like the first 13 15 episodes okay so
he's doing like each one each episode of
time has its own little forum so if you
want to go over there and check that out
if you're you know if you're into Reddit
or whatever then there's a board now
there for you to discuss with other fans
also I think in the last episode we did
about a haunting which was last week's
yeah you would ask that you wanted to
hear some people's paranormal
experiences so I actually had to yeah we
had two guys that I asked in the Senate
in there yeah Christopher and Liam and
they sent me their paranormal
experiences so if they're cool with it
on next week's show which will probably
be another paranormal show then I'll
probably use their stories as kind of
like the news or okay no because they
were kind of they were really
interesting stories if you send us the
stories go ahead and confirm with us on
you know in the comment section yeah I'm
not gonna like use your last name or
anything like that cuz I don't put like
people's pictures in the YouTube videos
if they don't say it's okay I don't use
their last names because I'm just
assuming that you know you don't want
there might be some weirdo out there
looking you up or whatever so I so I
just use people's first names generally
but yeah so that's what I would do I'm
you know I'm not gonna like out for
anything right I also won his and this
is really cool this was actually sent to
my facebook author page which is just
Jenny Ashford author and here was a guy
named Brian and he had just ordered a
print copy of my book the faceless
villain and he said that he was so
excited about getting it that his little
boy was like can I take a picture of all
of us with the book and then I took a
picture of him go have him in the little
boy with the book and it was such a it
was adorable picture yeah and he said
that his son I couldn't tell how old he
was he's pretty little and he said his
son had just written his first chapter
book okay good and I was like oh that's
awesome I hope he like grows up and
becomes a writer if that's what he
really wants to do yeah if he if he
needs advice when he gets a little bit
older just you know put that on screen
no yeah I don't want to do that cuz like
I said okay you don't have permission
yeah and like I said and people I don't
like to put pictures of other people's
kids like yeah it's already okay so what
we're gonna do this is sort of in lieu
of a news story because it's not super
current but it's something that I kind
of came across while I was researching a
news story and it's something that we've
kind of touched upon a few times in some
of our other true crime shows all right
and this was what we perceived as the
decline of serial killers okay a serial
murder right yeah I noticed that
yeah and I wasn't sure if this was just
something that we were perceiving or if
this was something that was actually
happening and I came across I guess
there was a paper that came out in 2011
and it was called extreme killing
understanding serial and mass murder and
it was by a guy named James Alan Fox now
even though the paper came out in 2011
there were a lot of like think pieces
written about it like in the ensuing
years I found some from 2015 some from
2016 like Slade wrote one they were a
big long thing about it and the
interesting thing is that our perception
mmm was completely correct yeah I
thought so
the heyday of the serial killers is gone
the 70s and the 80s yeah now here's the
interesting thing at least in the United
States at least in the United States
yeah this is this is not a worldwide
phenomenon necessarily this is just
we're talking about the US
in the 1970s there were more than 500
serial murders in the United States not
murderers
yet serial murder serial crimes right
the 1980s was the peak just over 600
serial murders in the 2000s 2000 to 2009
there were 61 serial murders dramatic
drop yes right so they're trying to this
paper that this guy wrote was kind of
trying to unpack the reasons for why
that could be one of the reasons he came
up with is probably the most obvious
reason is that since you know we have
DNA now we have more update like
technological advances in crime solving
and things like that
maybe we're catching people earlier
before they can become serial killers
you know you don't get this thing where
there's like years and years where they
don't know who this dude is also they
speculate that maybe it's harder to find
victims just because people tend to be
more wary they Google people before they
date them they you know they they're
more suspicious and have means at their
disposal for checking people out
beforehand so it might be harder to find
victims which I think we did kind of
mention on our last on our last show
where we were talking about that now
there have been some exceptions
obviously we did a show about the Long
Island serial killer who actually used
Craigslist to retarget victims but the
paper says that that's actually not as
common as you would think it was I mean
I think because of relative anonymity
and things and you know escorts
particularly working on Craigslist you'd
think that would make it very easy for
someone to target killers but apparently
that is not the case and they're also
saying that it could be because serial
killers just are not romanticized in the
media I don't necessarily want to use
the romanticize because I don't think
they ever were no they weren't
romanticized but they're not it's not as
prevalent in the media as it used to be
there isn't the media anymore there's
just online and that's everything well
true and I do think people's interests
have definitely become more you know
niche where you can pretty much just see
what you want to see and yeah so so it's
not a thing where people are consuming
the same newspapers consuming the same
news and they're all saying stories
about Ted Bundy or John Wayne Gacy or
the zodiac or whatever so the whole
country is kind of gripped in this panic
you don't really see that
as much anymore because it's just not
right it's not as generalizer and it
could be to that because it's not as
generalized people don't necessarily go
go that route when they want easy fame
although the paper did point out that
although serial killings are far less
common mass shootings are a lot more
prevalent well that's because they're
being promoted basically they kind of
that's kind of the point that they're
making is they look at these look at
these school shooter kids they're all
kind of that same profile you know like
that one that shot up to school here in
Florida just a few months back they
actually released a video that he took
of himself and when you see that dude
talk and you go yeah it's the same dork
like those other dorks
yes it's there just in sales basically
and it's and it's the same kind of thing
it's you know that's a very similar
profile and this is like a way for like
I said powerless dudes to it's like one
dude I saw one dork do it right then
they're gonna do good so I mean like
although like we said violent crime in
general has been declining precipitously
since 1900 matter what they say it's
actually decline stable yeah yeah you
just hear about it more I was talking to
some young kid so well that we're not
really young kids but people in their
20s to us that's like young kids now do
you don't know what you're talking about
every era yeah that you know they don't
know what they're talking about the 70s
in the 80s we're just off to change it
yeah way worse yeah it's weird because I
think the problem is nowadays like I
says oversaturation you just hear about
stuff a lot more than you did back in
the day so it seems like it's everywhere
even if it's actually not occurring as
often yeah they kill people in some
little area except for people and it
would only make the local news yeah when
you make the national news right back in
the newspaper day you know yeah because
why would anybody I mean like I said and
I and this was a problem that I came at
what's not a problem necessarily but
that I've been coming across as I'm
researching my the second volume of my
book is that a lot of these unsolved
murders even when they were super
gruesome or super crazy even if it was a
serial killer it was like several
related murders in one area it didn't
really go beyond the bounds of
the town of the town that it was in I
mean I discovered a whole series of
crazy murders in Ontario yeah that
happened in the late 60s and you never
hear about it right it was just it was
just local news it was just kind of
local news finding this particularly in
the 50s and 60s it was a very common
problem so you know nowadays it's like
something happens in butt-fuck yeah
Arkansas you you everybody knows
everybody knows yeah they know about it
in Europe oh my god those American so it
seems so you know so it seems like it's
a lot more prevalent just because you're
hearing about it more I think that's the
only problem but I'm just I'm just gonna
go as far to say that the conditions are
no longer correct for creating serial
killers for one reason or another and I
I actually gonna stick to my leaded fuel
theory that you know what like I said I
don't think I've ever seen anybody
brought that up but that might be there
in there putting lead inside gasoline
all right well it's supposed to quiet
the valves to keep your valves tapping
right you know and to help seal valves
on top of an old motor well coming out
with that exhaust pipes a bunch of
little LED particles and they're blowing
and blowing around a clear basis yeah
right and all the cities are just got
these little microscopic little
particles lead everywhere they're
breathing that in and you know Laura let
it fuel start to be phased out in the
80s yeah right along with the decline of
all that stuff yeah because look at all
the brain damage and stuff like that
that little kids would get like from
eating metal paint and stuff how crazy
Romans were yeah drinking out of lead
pipes and all eating off the lead plates
yeah they did crazy stuff it lowers your
IQ it makes you very violent yeah it
makes you crazy well it's a way it takes
away inhibitions yeah because it messes
with your frontal lobe right to an
extent so even though I'm not sure
breathing it in obviously is probably
not as harmful as say eating it like it
was lead paint but I'm sure it has an
effect so there might be I mean that
might not be the main issue even a
contributing factor right but that might
have been a contributing factor because
I think most of the factors are probably
cultural you know having to do with how
we do police work nowadays and things
but you know I definitely think that
could probably be some kind of yeah the
environmental factor the United States
was going through a lot of transitions
at that time I was like transitional
period from pretty religiously dominated
country into a more secular country
imagine if you took Saudi Arabia and
made it
secular country overnight and there'd be
a lot of problems you know too many
because any kind of change it's going to
cause social upheaval because some
people aren't gonna like it some people
are gonna like it and there's gonna be a
lot of fun that's two things the United
States was kind of like one long social
upheaval really through the whole thing
civil wars foundations of new states
conquering territory and again what you
know the reason why so many killers
probably serial killers peaked in like
late 60s to mid 80s was because we were
coming out of the whole Cultural
Revolution of the late 60s and you know
there was so much upheaval there we
forget about all the religious strife
but all the different types of
Protestantism yeah it was fighting each
other yeah and Catholics and here in the
United says you know we don't think
about it today but yeah it's funny it's
really not even on the radar nobody 1970
oh well yeah oh yeah so okay so that was
something that I thought was kind of
interesting because it kind of went back
to what we were talking we were probably
talking about our Golden State killer
show yeah and I just thought it was
interesting that I discovered something
that was talking about the very thing we
were talking about so I go then that
happens all right so let's get to the
main topic which is about the infamous
phantom killer also known as the
moonlight murderer or the tech sarcana
moonlight murder sometimes it's called
they usually call it that because
there's a perception that it was that
the murders well not even a perception
it kind of was but the murders were
three weeks apart okay you know like
phases of the Moon phases of the Moon
right now I actually wrote about this
case in my in the first volume of the
faceless villain it's also been
requested several times and this is
something I kind of wanted even though
it's kind of a well known case it's
something that I kind of wanted to get
into and I think it's kind of an
interesting it's he has like a lot of
parallels with the zodiac really I mean
he targeted the same kind of people he
had the same he had a hood he had the
same kind of thing he didn't really it
wasn't like a taunting the police type
situation but you know you can see where
maybe zodiac could have got the idea now
the interesting thing about this is that
if you guys have seen the documentary we
saw it I think it's on Netflix still
it's called killer legends you remember
we saw that word that where there was
those two people and they were exploring
the right it was like four or five
different urban legends and they were
trying to figure out trace back where
they came from now they made this
statement on there I can't remember how
definitive
they stated this but they said that they
thought that the urban legend of the
hook you know everybody knows the story
of the hook going out to the lovers
lanes and you know there's an escaped
mental patient and oh we got to get out
of here right away and then there's a
hook on the door handle and whatnot that
actually that might have been inspired
by the phantom killer now I looked it up
and while the Wikipedia page about this
urban legend doesn't make that specific
Association I will note that the legend
of the hook did not become prevalent
until the mid to late 50s which was
about 10-15 years after the Phantom
killer murders the first mention of the
hook urban legend was actually in a Dear
Abby column from the 1960 where someone
was repeating it as a supposedly true
story which is the definition of an
urban legend having to a friend of a
friend but so it's possible that it
could be even though there's no hook
involved in this it's possible you can
see where the idea of it could have come
from so this started in 1946 this was an
unapprehended serial killer they still
have not much idea who he is his reign
of terror only lasted about four months
and then he never killed again so now
the first people to be attacked and this
was Friday February 22nd 1946 so you got
Jimmy Hollis he's 25 and his girlfriend
Mary Jean Larrey who is 19 they've gone
to the movies and then after the movies
they're gonna go out and park like
people did back in the old days they
Park and make out so they go to Lovers
Lane
they've only been sitting in the car for
about 10 minutes then someone comes up
to the driver's side window and shines a
flashlight into the window yeah Jimmy
can't really see that's a cop yeah he
didn't really think anything of it he
just thought it was a joke or you know
this is maybe somebody that is mistaking
me for someone else or whatever now the
guy says get out of the car so they both
get out like I said possibly thinking
it's a cop and then they see that it's a
guy with a hood and he's pointing a
pistol with them that does sound kind of
like that zodiac doesn't yeah this
that's what I mean that's right this
might have been words OD AK got the idea
because there's a lot of parallels so
the guy says to them okay do what I say
and I won't hurt you
yeah then he says to Jimmy quote take
off your [ __ ] britches he says I am
so Mary jeans tells Jim he's just like
just dude he says it's you know it'll be
fine he just wants money or
whatever so then Jimmy does what he's
told he takes off his pants and then the
guy cracks Jimmy in the head they're not
sure if he did it with the pistol but or
if he had something else maybe did it
with a flashlight yeah it could have
been the flashlight or he could have had
some other some other thing I'm Mary
Jean said that his head getting hit was
so loud that she thought the guy had
shot him that's how loud it was yet so
then she tries to reason with the guy
she says look we don't have any money
it's like you know just leave us alone
or whatever the man said you know you're
lying yes you do and then he knocked her
to the ground also she said she didn't
know what it was but it felt like an
iron pipe he then told her to get up off
the ground and start running hmm which
she did yeah she starts running in one
direction he's like no not that way goes
that way yeah so she's like okay
whatever so she runs and then she hears
Jimmy getting the [ __ ] beat out of him
like behind her and she is freaking out
right she sees a car and she goes up to
it thinking someone's in there for help
but it's empty his car probably that's
what I was thinking it was probably the
car that he drove there but you know she
didn't know so now she had my heels on
like I said she wasn't running very fast
the guy caught up with her and then he
says to her why are you running she says
because you told me to hmm and then he
accused her of lying again knocks her on
the ground and then proceeds to sexually
assault her with the barrel of the
pistol okay Wow at which point she kind
of throws him she fights him and throws
him off and then just says you know what
just kill me if you're gonna do that
just kill me mmm but then at this point
I think that a car pulled up and they
saw some headlights so the guy ran off
so she runs to a house and gets help an
ambulance comes Jimmy has AI is actually
still alive his skull has been fractured
in three places but he was okay enough
that he could kind of get to his feet he
flagged down a car and they called him
an ambulance so both of these two
survived yeah we got lucky right the
later ones would not be wrong but these
two yeah these two did survive now
because the whole situation they hadn't
got a good look at the dude obviously
she said Mary Jane had seen him but he
had what looked like she said it was
either a pillowcase or some kind of a
white sack or over his face that just
had little holes cut out for the eyes
and mouth and that's it now Jimmy said
well okay he was about six feet tall
which Mary Jean also said Jimmy thought
that he was maybe a tanned
white dude right maryjean thought that
he was maybe a light-skinned black man
but neither of them could tell they can
only see his hands right and hear his
voice so they couldn't really tell and
Mary Jean was she said something about
when the police were questioning her
about it she later said that she thought
the police were trying to get her to
admit that she knew who he was right she
said but that is not the case we do not
know this was just a random dude yeah
the cops do the cops thought that maybe
it was it was a set up some sort she was
yeah either that well and the thing too
is that because this had happened and
like I said if I didn't mention it
before this in 1946 this was in
Texarkana Texas you're not from here
it's right on the border between Texas
and Arkansas yeah
so at first the police I mean they took
it seriously obviously but they treated
it as an isolated incident that maybe it
was a robbery or an attempted rape and
they didn't really expect I mean they
didn't they didn't think it was gonna be
random either right they yeah they
didn't really think of it as random and
there was no really no such thing as
like serial killer profiling I mean
nobody came up and said oh this sounds
like a serial killer in the making or
anything like that well obviously they
were a her percent wrong about that
so skip ahead to March 23rd here we have
Richard Griffin who was 29 he had a
girlfriend in Pali and Moore he was 17
about 10:00 p.m. they're having dinner
with his sister and the sisters
boyfriend at some cafe like outside of
Texarkana and after they finished their
dinner they don't kind of go off in
their separate ways and then Richard and
Polly Ann disappear the next morning
which was a Sunday morning there's a guy
and he's driving past this place called
rich Road which was kind of an unpaved
Lovers Lane again he saw a 1941
Oldsmobile that looked like two people
were sleeping in it so he goes up and
looks in there and sees that both of
them have been shot in the head
damn so he calls the police now Richard
Griffin he was they found him he was
kneeling between the front seats of the
car okay his pockets had been turned
inside-out his head was resting on his
hands he had been shot twice both times
in the back of the head I think or in
the back of the head and once in the
neck or something of that nature Polly
Ann was in the back seat facedown she
was shot in the back of the head
although she wasn't shot in the car
police thought that I mean there was
blood
side of the car and the cars running
board so they thought that whoever had
taken her out of the car forced her out
of the car shot her and then put her
back in the backseat yeah so she wasn't
shot inside the car now both of the
victims were fully clothed the sad thing
was that Polly and more I mean
considering the later crimes she was
probably raped yeah but they took her to
the coroner like almost me without
really checking any of that so by the
time they got through all of the
post-mortem and everything I'm assuming
because everything I've read about the
case said that they never determined
whether she had been ditched but I
assume that it is a likelihood yeah
according to the evidence that you're
describing
yeah the guy was shot in the front seat
all right the girl was raped outside and
then killed outside and then dumped into
the car right that why he didn't want to
rape the girl with a dead guy in the
front seat right now they did find there
was a blanket inside the car and it had
a 32 caliber cartridge shell they
thought this had come from a Colt
automatic okay so a very small pistol
cartridge yeah now they thought that
robbery might have been part of the
motive since they didn't find any money
either in Polly Ann's purse or in his
pockets and as I said the pockets had
been turned inside out so they're
assuming again that oh maybe it was just
it's a random robbery and they just shot
the people and like I said they didn't
determine whether Polly and had been
raped her
so at this stage I don't really think I
mean they did kind of not really link
the two crimes even though obviously
they're very similar it's it's easy to
kind of Monday Morning Quarterback and
look back and go well obviously this is
the same perpetrator I mean you know
they did pretty much the exact same as a
Lovers Lane it was a couple they were
sitting in a car someone approached them
with a gun but it at this stage still it
doesn't seem like they were like oh
serial killers so their question in
suspects over 200 people at one point
but all were eventually cleared a few
days after the murder about four days
afterward they approached the Texarkana
Gazette you know the main newspaper in
town and pretty much asked the public
for help if anybody saw anything you
know can you please help us out we
really we're really in the weeds here
pretty much so they're still working on
this crime and then about three weeks
later just like clockwork there was
another one right so he's doing it three
week
hermits more or less yeah pretty much
okay now I guess since we're kind of at
the halfway point right now so maybe
I'll stop here and then we'll go okay to
the next case and then yeah because
there's other stuff I want to get into
the phantom killer the rest of the
phantom killer murder is kind of the
suspects and that I want to get into a
little bit into the movie the town that
dreaded sundown and where it deviated
from the actual crime and I also want to
talk if I have time I want to talk a
little bit about the disappearance of
Virginia carpenter which is sometimes
linked in with this crime okay okay so
we're gonna take a break right now
that's right back in just a few minutes
kick back and listen to some commercials
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right now we're back so this is the
second week of April it's April 13th
1946 there's a girl named Betty Jo
Booker she's 15
she plays saxophone not trombone in a
band that plays at the VFW every
Saturday night so this is a Saturday
night and she's playing at the VFW with
her band there called the rhythm airs
just like she does every Saturday night
now ordinarily Betty Jo would get a ride
home with either the bandleader or one
of the other guys in the band they would
usually give her a ride home after the
gig but on this particular Saturday
she was actually getting a ride home
from her friend Paul Martin who was 16
and she was they were not a couple but
he was an old friend of hers he you know
she'd known him since kindergarten he
had moved away but he was visiting back
in town so she kind of she kind of felt
obligated to hang out with him so you
know so he was gonna pick her up now he
was actually supposed to pick her up
from the gig at 1:00 a.m. and then he
was supposed to take her to her friend's
house cuz her friend was having a
slumber party
okay well the night goes on and I mean
she leaves he picks her up obviously but
they never turn up at the slumber party
so the next morning about 6 o'clock in
the morning one of the girls it was at
the slumber party calls the bandleader
whose name was Jerry Atkins and was like
hey where's Betty Jo she was supposed to
come to my party and she didn't come
right and Jerry was like oh well I think
it was the other guys the other band
members turned to drive her home so
maybe you should call him or call her
parents or whatever so you know he's
like cuz I didn't see her so about half
an hour after this phone call there's
this family The Weavers and they're
driving down this road and they see a
body on the side of the road that's a
teenage boy he's just laying there and
this is Paul Martin he had been shot
four times once in the back once through
the hand once through the nose and once
through the back of the neck me guess 32
caliber it was yeah yeah so at this
stage they see him they're like well
that's Paul Martin where's Betty Jo so
they get a search party together and
they fan out in all directions took
about four hours to find her she was
about two miles away
she was also she was shot twice actually
once in the chest once in the face like
you said both victims shot with a 32
caliber Colt automatic pistol
Betty Jo was found fully clothed but had
been raped they say they found that out
at the post-mortem that's why I'm saying
that Polly and more probably was as well
so half a mile away from where Paul
Martin's body was found they found his
car with the keys still in it they never
could figure out which one of them was
killed first but she was actually kind
of far away from the car so she had
obviously been taken some distance
unlike the movie the town that dreaded
sundown which showed Betty Jo Booker
getting killed with a trombone with her
own trombone that had like a knife on
the end yeah yeah what is that slightly
part of the trombone Cobb no the slide I
think it is called the slide it called
the slide okay I'm sure it has a name
but but that is actually what's called a
slide trombone so that's probably the
slide yeah yeah that's not the case oh
she was a saxophone player and actually
they didn't find her saxophone until
much later so they didn't even recover
it from the scene it wasn't there and
actually that was one of the main clues
that they used at the beginning to try
to solve the murder is that because her
saxophone was not found and they knew
that she had left with it the musical
instrument had a serial number so they
gave the serial number to all the pawn
shops and [ __ ] like that in the area to
see if someone came in and tried to pawn
it and at this stage this is when the
Texas Rangers get involved
the State Police kind of all the City
Police gonna because now they're finally
they finally understand that this is a
serial killer this is someone that's
targeting couples in cars and they kind
of need to get off their asses and get
this [ __ ] together and this is also the
stage where the media I believe it was
the tech sarcana Gazette the editor of
the techs are Kanak is that that gave
the killer the name the phantom killer
okay because I mean there are they're
all going by the first description of
him right that Mary Jean Larrey gave
because she was really the only one that
got a good look at him nobody else did
everybody else was dead now
interestingly concerning the saxophone
that Betty Jo Booker had had so April
25th which was only a little more than a
week after Betty Jo Booker and Paul
Martin got killed this guy walks into a
pawn shop in Corpus Christi and he says
hey do you want to buy an alto saxophone
he didn't have it with him but he asked
the girl at the music store do you want
to buy one and she said oh well you know
I'll have to ask my
manager right now she said at this stage
the guy got very agitated it was like
why do you have to ask your manager and
so she said well I just have to and so
she went to call the manager and then
the guy left right now they did track
down this guy two days later they found
him in a hotel in Corpus Christi they
someone had spotted him trying to buy a
45 at a pawn shop
right now they didn't find the saxophone
he didn't have it they did find in his
hotel room there was a bag of bloody
clothes that looked like his clothes but
that had blood on them right now he said
he'd been in a bar fight right yeah
which is what they all say but the more
they questioned this guy I'm they pretty
much determined that wasn't him I mean
it's suspicious as he seemed ok dude he
didn't seem to be linked to these
murders right he didn't seem to be
linked to that not saying it wasn't a
sketchy [ __ ] but it's weird
aside from this being the 1940s this is
very textbook case kind of serial killer
activity I mean it's pretty much you
know Berkowitz zodiac what's the other
one it was kind of like this
Starkweather was a little bit like this
yeah kinda yellow he had all the more
spree killer more spree killer yeah he
he seems generic at this point very
generic it's just that he's kind of one
of them he's an early motorised serial
killer that's what is how I'd classify
this that's actually a good way of
putting it because this is kind of I
mean the 40s were kind of the dawn of
the American car culture yeah and it was
kind of you know you got your highway
system first kind of coming to fruition
got most people after the war being able
to afford cars yeah and so like you said
it's almost like the first guy that's
like driving or riding around doing it
targeting people in their own cars right
prior to this you had Jack the Ripper
type guys guys that walked around and
stabbed hookers yeah basically or
stabbed farm families never killed them
with X exactly you had a lot of that
this is a guy who drives around hunting
victims seemingly teenage couples steals
what he can from him but I think the
motive is rape problem with the motive
is robbery it's real even though I mean
yeah some of the victims were robbed but
some of them weren't
and its might have been just like a case
of opportunity like oh they got some
money hanging
take that I don't think that was the
motivation the first few is him trying
to build up his you know confidence and
then once he's confident with it he
eventually goes for the gold which was
the girls the rape yeah that's what he's
doing cuz this is a very common pattern
that you see with serial killers their
first few attempts right don't worry you
don't work out like and I said and it
was the case in this that you know they
they got beat up she got sexually
assaulted not raped penetrated raped but
she did he did penetrate her with
another object he was too nervous he
couldn't rise to the occasion right
exactly
couldn't get it up and he didn't and he
did beat them she was beaten also was
she had a big cut on her face and things
but he didn't kill them yeah he wasn't
there for that and he was there to rape
that girl yeah and I do feel like that
service so like I said even though it's
never been determined whether the second
woman Pauline Moore was raped I assume
that she probably well I'm gonna say we
don't know this guy is yet you haven't
really painted out the suspect but I'm
gonna say 20s that's what I'm gonna say
so far we'll see sounds like the crime
of a man in his 20s mid 20s now the
weird thing so that so the guy that went
to the pawn shop and tried to pawn the
saxophone he was actually in police
custody until May 3rd at which point
they released him because they didn't
think he had any connection to the
crimes now on May 3rd this was when the
phantom killer struck for what was
presumably the last time these are
though these are the last two canonical
crimes one of which was a murder one of
the victims survived but this was
actually almost like and like I said
this is another thing you see patterns
with serial killers it was like an
escalation because he this time did not
target a couple in a car he targeted a
couple in their house he's getting more
and more bold
this was actually Virgil Starks who was
a farmer he was 37 he and his wife Katie
lived on this 500 acre farm and it was
kind of outside of town so it wasn't
really in that close to where the other
murders were committed so it's the night
of May 3rd the couple is at home Katie
gives her husband he had a bad back so
she gave him a heating pad and he kind
of sat in his little comfy chair in the
living room and turned on the radio to
listen to his show and he had his paper
and he was sitting there and she goes in
the bedroom to lay down then Katie hears
something in the backyard and she yells
out to Virgil hey turn the
so I can see what that is I think I
heard somebody then from the living room
she hears glass breaking now she didn't
think anything bad at first she thought
oh well Virgil's dropped something and
broken so she goes out to the living
room she sees her husband stand up from
his chair and then he falls back down
like he slumps back down in my chair
well a whole enemy so she yeah she runs
up to him and looks and there's two
bullet holes in the back of his head and
then she looks and the window three feet
behind him has two bullet holes in it
yeah he shot through the window got it
yes
so she flips out she runs to the phone
calls the police and then the killer
shoots her right in the face
yeah one of the bullets it went through
the side of her face yeah and it came
out behind her ear and then the other
one hit her underneath the jaw yeah it
blew her lips out and a bunch of her
teeth yeah so her face is just like
covered in blood yeah but you know
what's strange is that's usually
non-lethal it wasn't this guy she did
live yeah because the brain is above all
that yeah you can shoot the face in the
face and then she said that she saw the
guy trying to climb in the window hmm so
she ran the [ __ ] out of that house and
there's just blood everywhere with like
teeth are falling out over 32 actually
doesn't do a whole lot of damage it's a
small and pointed bullet makes it wound
very similar to an icepick most of the
time looks like an icepick wound but
good penetration blew her teeth out
though yeah pieces of teeth and yeah
I've seen calibers like that 380 you
know what it does little animals and
things you know growing up so she was
actually able to run out of the house
she ran down the street to her
neighbor's house the neighbor called the
police and she actually did survive now
when the police went into the house
Virgil Starks had been killed outright
the well not funny the ironic thing was
that the heating pad that he had behind
him had actually caught the chair that
he was sitting in on fire damn so they
had to put that out but yeah he died she
actually survived although she didn't
get a very good look at him he had a
mask on she said she just saw a dark
form like coming in the window and then
got the [ __ ] out of the house as you
would now when you were saying but a 32
these two were actually shot with a 22
rifle so the guy got shot in the back of
the head in the face it was little - I
was a 22 rifle yeah okay both real
common in the batteries super common
cheap and plentiful small high-quality
32 automatic
those were super super plentiful in the
40s and the 50s even up into the 60s it
was a really practical caliber and then
the pistols were cheap well-built and
accurate and of course 22 rifles were
just everywhere all over the United
States they're all over the United
States today you know that's just your
standard ranch gun you could get a good
one for a hundred bucks today yeah used
there was some speculation about whether
this crime had been committed by the
same perpetrator just because the weapon
was different and the method was
different yeah
but in general this is considered the
last of the phantom killer murders they
gave up though he didn't go in there and
get her yeah well she ran out and I
guess he probably figured now the only
thing they did recover some fingerprints
from the scene there were some partial
bloody footprints that were presumably
like Miller it makes sense though if the
motive was rape why the hell would you
want to rape a girl who had her face
blown off probably way you let her go
now he did not rob this house apparently
these farms uh you know this farm family
they had a lot of money a lot of cash on
hand in the house yeah and it wasn't
hidden or anything but he didn't take
anything from the house it didn't look
like and the only thing like I said they
got fingerprints they got some
footprints they actually found a red and
black flashlight he had abandoned
outside of the window that Virgil was
shot through well I guess he figured
that she was gonna go run for help so he
better guys yeah because you know the
police would be coming now even though
now at this stage even though the movie
the town that dreaded sundown pretty
much after the first set of two murders
the whole town like flipped the [ __ ] out
and everyone was doing this but honestly
but in reality it didn't really happen
until after the starks murders or kind
of in between the third set of murders
and the starks murders then the whole
town started flipping out the police
gave a midnight curfew you know people
were buying guns and guard dogs and yard
lights and fences and new locks and all
this other stuff
people were booby trapping their houses
yeah there were a bunch of teenagers who
thought they'd be superheroes and they
took to staking out lovers lanes
you know they armed themselves and
they're sitting
yeah trying to get the killer to come
out and you know try to attack him so
they could shoot him
now the police did that also they did
that too but the killer never took this
bait he sounds like a drifter
he asked me this sounds like a drifter a
guy who was only in town for a little
while anyway
it might have been there on a job or
something right then left now during the
investigation as I said Virgil and Cady
Starks were the last ones that were
attacked that they know of there were a
couple of weird little things that went
on now a few days after this about four
days after the Starks were attacked they
found a man named Earl McSpadden and he
was found lying on the railroad tracks
dead about 16 miles north of Texarkana
his arm and leg had been cut off I guess
by the train but police thought that he
might have been murdered before the
train came that he was dead for two
hours and then somebody left him on the
track you know make it look make it look
like that there's still kind of rumors
in Texarkana that Earl McSpadden might
have been the Phantom and that he
committed suicide by jumping in front of
a train or some people consider Earl
McSpadden the sixth victim of the
Phantom that has never been determined
they don't the mo yeah that's that
really doesn't doesn't sound like the
same kind of thing then it's unrelated
there were also a couple of weird things
now also on the same day this was four
days after the Starks murder May 7th a
man named Herbert Thomas comes to the
police and he says you know I was
driving and this guy came up to me he
was hitchhiking he said hey I have to go
to Henderson which is a nearby town he
said I'll give you $5.00 my mom is very
sick and I should go see her the guy
gets in the car he drives the guy to
Henderson and then the guy pulls out a
pistol and says keep on driving or I'll
kill you just like I killed those people
in Texarkana right so now this guy
that's talking to the police he says the
guy said Betty Jo Booker's name and Paul
Martin's name it sounds like a boast
yeah and said oh I'm not done killing
I'm still gonna kill more people then he
takes back the $5 he takes another $3
that the driver had and then he says
okay don't follow me I'm gonna kill you
yeah that sounds like guys bragging but
then so he lets the guy out and then
later on that night
another guy in the town where he dropped
him off yeah said that he saw like a
prowler around his house that that had
the same kind of description so I don't
know if this was the same guy or if it
was just somebody showing off or what it
does it doesn't sound right to me
you got the perpetrator first of all
started he had to have his own
transportation his own car he's very
careful he's committed to what maybe six
to eight six homicides at least and
nobody's seen him and he's getting away
he wouldn't be bragging about that the
guy who committed all those murders was
stealthy and kept his mouth shut I think
he was a drifter a bit yeah it could be
a guy in his 20s probably and like I
said there were a couple other weird
things like there was this guy named
Ralph Baumann he got arrested in LA on
May 23rd and he said that he woke up
from a coma on May the 3rd and he
couldn't remember anything that had
happened before that and he said now
I've been hearing all this stuff about
the phantom killer suspect this
hitchhiker yeah who had red hair and
kind of looked like this guy looked and
he's like and I'm wondering if it's me
because I don't remember anything that
happened so he turned himself into
police yeah but the police determined
that he had actually been discharged
from the Army because of Bentall profile
Yeah right and that there was probably
no connection now here though is where
this guy is kind of the prime suspect so
June 28 1946 there's this police officer
from Arkansas max Tackett and he sees a
car parked in a parking lot that was
reported stolen on the same night that
Richard Griffin and Polly Ann Moore were
murdered okay this is sounding promising
so he says okay well I'm gonna sit here
and see who gets in this car right who
gets in the car was a 21 year old woman
and her name is Peggy Swinney okay so he
arrests her you know obviously this is a
stolen car now it turned out that Peggy
had just married a guy named Ewell
Swinney both of them were car thieves
okay after they were both taken into
custody for stealing this car Peggy says
to the police yeah you'll swoon he's a
car thief Oh also he's the Phantom
killer huh so you will says why would
she give up that information right
here's the thing now there are two
schools of thought about this now you'll
Swinney when he was getting arrested for
the car theft
he did say some kind
weird things that made the police think
that me maybe he said stuff like when
the police were arresting well the first
thing he said when they were arresting
him for stealing the car the first thing
you said was don't shoot me and the cop
was like we're not gonna shoot you just
for stealing a car it's not that big a
deal
we're just arresting you but then he
would say stuff like I know you're
playing with me you're arresting me for
more than car theft am I gonna get the
chair okay would say stuff like that so
it sounded very incriminating right so
that gave some people pause now he also
Peggy thought that he was the Phantom
killer apparently some of her relatives
also thought that he was the Phantom
killer he admitted that he had once
owned a 32 Colt automatic pistol
although he had since lost it in a craps
game they always seem to lose him in
card games yeah yeah people tend to
they're always betting guns and cars and
car games you know like you do now it
should be noted that you will Swinney
never admitted to any of those crimes
right he was open about the car theft
well car theft in the 40s wasn't a huge
penalty for not like today the United
States you know grand theft auto can
bring ten years yes bang on the states
you know back in those days you probably
lucky to get five months for something
like that 90 days what eventually ended
up happening see cuz here's the thing
like I said you'll swinney is still
considered even now is still considered
the prime suspect
even though Peggy Sweeney the wife you
know yeah she thought he was the Phantom
killer but the more they interviewed her
they were like she seems like a habitual
liar right
she wasn't super compelling as a witness
and at any rate evidently the laws at
the time and I'm not sure if it's still
the same and that in that state but
husbands and wives couldn't testify
against one another right you know I
mean because there was conflict in
writers or whatever so so she wouldn't
have been able to take the stand against
him anyway even if they did try him for
that now they also determined one the
fingerprints that were found at the
scene of the Virgil Starks murder did
not match you when he's fingerprints
right they also were able to determine
that on the night of at least one of the
murders both Ewell and Peggy Swinney
were probably in San Antonio so they're
just liars really so so I'm not
sure I mean they're gonna sound right
now like I said there was some other
circumstantial evidence though now the
car that they found Peggy sweaty and
obviously was a car that had been stolen
the same night that Paulie and more in
Russia performer it's showing that they
were in that town but it wasn't stolen
from a victim though no but it was
stolen and so that put them in the town
it's a coincidence I betcha but there
was also the weird [ __ ] he said about
when he got arrested oh we gonna get the
chair ba bla also Peggy she actually
seemed to know some things about the
crime scenes that weren't common
knowledge like she actually went with
some of the officers to one of the crime
scenes and said oh yeah I walked over
here and they said oh well we did find
like a woman's high-heeled footprints
over here and we didn't tell the media
that I'm suspicious um you'll sweat E's
room like the his bedroom they found a
work shirt and there was a khaki work
shirt and it had a laundry mark on it
that said Stark which was you know
similar to the last name one of the
victims it also had something like some
kind of slag in the pocket that matched
some slag from the Virgil Starks is
welding shop huh you know so there was
that but like I said you know there was
the thing about fingerprints not
matching you know during one or two of
the murders they were probably in
another town doesn't it doesn't really
jive up with me cuz these crimes are
actually the crimes of a single male
yeah that's a that's usually this
overwhelming that's who's gonna be doing
this it's gonna be a loner yeah a loner
type male he's not gonna have a
girlfriend and sigh I don't think these
two did that now interesting when I was
watching something that came out because
the town that dreaded sundown the
original movie which was directed by
Charles V Pierce of Legend of Boggy
Creek Fame that actually came out in the
70s 1976 I believe it was and they did a
remake of it
in 2014 2016 I want to say right around
that time that came out there was a book
that came out about the phantom killer
and the book was written by a guy named
John Presley who was actually the nephew
of one of the main investigators on the
case now he thinks that you'll Swinney
was the phantom killer and he's been
researching it for a long time yeah so
I'm not you know I'm not gonna [ __ ] on
because I don't know as much about the
case as him obviously but he thinks and
there's also a criminal profiler that
they talked to on this same duct
that I saw that also thinks that it was
him they know more about the case and I
do every night hearing about it right
now it just sounds like the work of a
single male that's just sort of lets you
know why would a guy I mean he had only
recently married that right it just
doesn't sound it's it it doesn't sound
like yeah it sure doesn't sound like him
now the interesting thing about Ewell
Swinney though is that even though they
couldn't get him for the murders
obviously but he was a car thief and
because at the time in the state they
had a law where if you had so many
offenses they could put you in jail for
life so they did they did yes similar
type of thing so he had stolen so many
cars and committed so many other crimes
that they said okay we'll just put him
in prison for that he was actually in
prison until 1973 so they let him out on
appeal because they determined in the
original trial he hadn't gotten you know
adequate representation or whatever
after he was let out he was actually in
and out of prison for quite a while
after that 16 just minor offenses mostly
car theft robbery that type of thing and
he didn't change his ways so they
actually finally let him out on parole
in 1989 when he was about 72 years old
and he died about five years later in a
nursing home so he has passed away since
then so whether he was the Phantom
killer or not no one will ever know now
here's a weird little thing and I don't
know here here was another suspect and
this is kind of creepy this happened a
couple years later this was November 5th
1948 and there was this guy named duty
Tennyson okay that was his nickname duty
his real name was Henry but he let
people call him Duty for a reason
just like Greece yeah but he killed
himself he was a student at the
University of Arkansas he actually
poisoned himself with rat poison and
here was the creepy thing they found
like this little they're like a lockbox
and he had this little poem that told
them how to open the lockbox and
everything the police were like [ __ ]
that they just you know broke it and
over here and inside there was a letter
there was a viewmaster with a bunch of
little reels of Mexico and then there
was a letter that said to whom it may
concern this is my last word to you find
people and you are fine I want to thank
you for all the trouble that you've gone
to to send me to college and to bring me
up you have been really wonderful why
did I take my own
well when you committed to double
murders you would - yes I did kill Betty
Jo Booker and Paul Martin in the city
park that night and killed mr. Starks
and tried to get mrs. Starks you
wouldn't have guessed it I did it when
mother was either out or asleep and no
one saw me do it for the guns i
disassembled them and discarded them in
different places when I am found which
has already been done please give this
typewriter to Craig who was his brother
and tell him that I hope his child is a
boy it will help him in his work
everything can go wherever you think it
will do best except for the viewmaster
which will go to Belva jo who was the
daughter of his please take my bankroll
and give it to Daddy I think it should
go to him and tell him I don't want the
car now goodbye everybody see you
sometime if I make the grade which will
be hard for me to make he had also
written like fake newspaper headlines
about his suicide like he had practiced
right yeah this was like the final he
had typed this note yeah but they found
like written drafts of it yeah I don't
believe it now it should be noted yeah
that he died in 1948 he was 18
which meant that he would have only been
16 committed which is possible he's
likely he's sighs he's fantasizing he's
grandstanding and fantasizing he's
killing himself for an imagined fantasy
crime you know how they have those guys
that like to commit or like to confess
to crimes that they didn't commit
yeah that's what he's doing yeah and
honestly like after that all happened
and they found this note and they're
like what the hell he had a friend from
Texarkana named James Freeman he came
forward and talked to the police and
he's like look on the night of this than
the other murder me and him were hanging
out yes playing cards at my house it's
like he didn't kill those people right
so no one knows it was just that was
just kind of a creepy little footnote
now yeah let me talk a little bit I mean
go a little bit into the town that
dreaded sundown no I have I've seen the
original it was many years ago I have
not seen the remake which is actually
the remake is actually kind of a meta
thing because see the town of Texarkana
in real life every year on Halloween
they show the town that dreaded sundown
rough-in I believe it's in Spring Lake
Park where some of the victims were
found which to me it's like kind of
morbid but also kind of awesome that
they do that okay I mean that's kind of
creepy but because those people are dead
and that's weird
but you know they're they're kind of
excited that a movie was made about in
their town I guess yeah so they're just
gonna show that movie every year like in
a big outdoor festival so apparently the
remake has a killer getting the idea
from the film festival now they're gonna
come back in the modern age and kill the
people or whatever no the guy who made
that movie that was the same guy who did
the Sasquatch movie wouldn't yeah I said
that earlier and he did Legend of Boggy
Creek yeah those it about and Legend of
Boggy Creek to tear which is actually
one of my favorite Mystery Science
Theater episodes oh my god that was his
hair hat and he's actually in it trying
to be Pierce's in actually he's in town
that tried to sundown to he plays a
small part he plays like a poverty god
that was him making those movies is the
only time he ever hung out with girls do
you know what's interesting though
what's it that Charles be pierced when
he made the town that dreaded sundown
his girlfriend at the time was the girl
that played the Betty Jo Booker
character the girl that got killed with
the stabby trombone which didn't really
happen
yeah and it's sad because that movie
came out and like I said it was more or
less accurate but the thing about the
trombone that was in the movie like I
think a lot of people think that that
was how Betty Jo didn't know they like I
said they'd even find her saxophone
until months after she died they found
it like in a field somewhere like and it
was still in the case right so you know
obviously the killer just taken it and
thrown it over a fence someplace which
you know that kind of negates the whole
guy that came into a pawn shop say and I
have an alto saxophone because they
didn't they found it a lot later so like
I said the movie they changed all the
victims names which you know fair enough
they can do that but a lot of the stuff
the trombone was inaccurate everybody in
the town freaking out about like the
second murder that was inaccurate it
didn't really happen until after the
third series and were just like right
before the Virgil Starks murders then
everybody started freaking out then they
did the they did the curfew everyone
stopped going out at night yeah this
other stuff so that happened much later
there was I think in the movie there was
a scene - during the Starks attack where
the police actually saw the perpetrator
and like chased him and that didn't
happen either he was long gone but
the time the cops got there so you know
the movie it's pretty accurate on its
face but you know there are some little
things and it's sad because it's fine
that they made a movie about it but the
fact that they made a movie about it
kind of tainted a lot of the actual
details of the case right you and it
became part of the mythology of the
phantom killer like I said really oh the
only person that got a good look at him
was Mary Jean Larrey the first victim
who didn't die is a co person and he had
a sack over his head and she couldn't
even really tell she's like me you know
could have been a tan white guy get a
light-skinned black she another race
yeah she didn't know her race it was
just she didn't get that good a look at
him no one did so she was the only one
that saw him and that's where the whole
mythology of the guy with and I think
even you know in Friday the 13th part 2
where you first see Jason before he has
the hockey mask and he has the bag of
resent run that might have been inspired
by this case because it does kind of
remind me of that now before we end I
actually want to talk a little bit about
Virginia carpenter because she's not
usually added to the canonical victims
because they never found her
she's just classified as a disappearance
I mean assuming that she was murdered
but the interesting thing about Virginia
carpenter is that she was from Texarkana
and she knew three of the victims hmm so
it seemed odd that she turned up missing
later on presumably murdered now this
was actually a couple years later this
was in 1948 she was originally from
Texarkana but she was actually going to
the Texas State College for Women which
was in Denton so she was taking a train
to the campus now on the train she met
up with another girl named Marjorie who
was also going to the same place and you
know they were both going to be living
on the campus in different dormitories
so they get off the train they share a
cab now the cab driver edgar ray zachary
he's kind of the last person that saw
her alive that they know of so they get
to the campus and she's like oh crap i
forgot to check and see like when my
trunk was coming in can you take me back
to the train station so marjorie who was
the other girl that she met on the train
she says well I can come back with you
and she's like no no it's fine so
Marjorie gets out she goes to her
dormitory Virginia goes back to the
train station they
your trunks not gonna commit til
tomorrow so then Edgar drives her back
to the campus and she says okay well can
you drive to the you know she's like
I'll pay you X amount of dollars drive
back to the train station tomorrow pick
up my trunk and then bring it back and
just leave it in the front office of the
dorm and I'll pick it up so he says fine
now he says that she gets out of the cab
and she has a couple suitcases with her
she says there's two guys you know like
a yellow or a cream-colored convertible
and they're parked on the curb a little
way up from the cab and he says now she
seemed to know who they were
he's like I distinctly heard her say
what are y'all doing here and they kind
of like hailed her like hey what's up
and so she goes over and talks to them
and then she says to Edgar she's like oh
they'll get my bags it's fine now he
couldn't really get a good look at them
because he said you know it was dark out
there was no moon that was like the
streetlights were out they were being
repaired at the time so he's like well
one of them was kind of tall and thin
one was short and fat that's about all I
can tell you but that you know these
were the last people that had been seen
with her now after that she disappeared
so days go by Edgar actually did go the
next day and he picked up her trunk from
the train station he brought it back to
the dorm he didn't take it to her room
though he actually left it on the lawn
Robbi he didn't want to go inside he
thought it was too much trouble or
whatever he just left it on the lawn and
then took off the suitcase sat there for
two days and then finally someone said
oh baby we should take that to the
office he took that the office so then
Virginia's boyfriend is like you know I
haven't heard from her for like three or
four days so he calls her mom and her
mom calls the school school says she
never came here she was supposed to come
register for classes she never showed up
so the weird thing about this is that
even though presumably we're presuming
that she disappeared on the last night
she was seen and maybe it was one of
these two guys in the yellow a
cream-colored convertible
she's never been found no they had never
found her and the sad thing is that you
know they interviewed the boyfriend it
wasn't him he lived far away anyway but
the creepy thing is that some people
claimed that they saw her in the ensuing
days now they don't think she was in any
particular trouble it's like she was
very excited to start school she wanted
to be a lab technician she'd actually
wanted to be a nurse she was always very
doctor she was very interested in the
sciences but she had a kind
where one of her legs was shorter than
the other I presume she had polio when
she was a child so she couldn't stand on
her feet for long periods of time so she
couldn't really be a nurse because you
kind of have to be able to stand up for
a long time so she's like well I'll just
be a lab tech you know kind of thing so
that's what she was going to college to
be she was very excited about it she'd
had a medical exam not long before she
wasn't pregnant or anything like that so
there was no reason for her to
voluntarily disappear is what they're
saying but there's also no real hard
link between her and this other case now
yeah the only thing that they think is
interesting about it like I said is that
she was originally from Texas arcana and
that she was friends with three of the
victims so so she does kind of sometimes
get linked in with this case because
they're saying maybe the person that did
those crimes later targeted her because
she knew something or something away
like that in the ensuing days some
people claimed that they saw her they
said you know one guy like at a service
station said oh I saw somebody that
looked like her it's like sorry
places like Texarkana back in those days
that everybody knew everybody I mean
they all went to school together that
really doesn't mean anything I'm just
saying this is a case that comes up as
kind of associated run because it just
seemed weird that she was from there and
she had known them and then late like a
couple years later she disappeared also
there's some towns of Mississippi small
actually small cities in Mississippi
where pretty much everybody knows
everybody in one way or another yeah I
don't think so but yeah so like I said
they've never figured out what happened
at Virginia carpenter I mean sort of
guilty yeah obviously you know like I
said there were some sightings of her
afterward you know somebody at a bus
station into Queen Arkansas said yeah I
saw a girl that looked just like her she
was getting off a bus from Texarkana she
met a young man who had sandy hair she
left with him and then she said a few
minutes after they left somebody called
the bus station and asked for her which
I don't know if that's true or not but
that's already weird if that's true
in 1955 which was seven years after she
disappeared they declared her dead so
that they grow you know do whatever they
had to do now four years after that in
1959 there was police came across I'm
not really sure I don't know if it was a
tip or something like that but they
found like in this old abandoned farm at
in Jefferson Texas
they found some human bones now the farm
was abandoned but they contacted the
family who had lived there at the time
and they're like what's with these bones
that we found on your land they said Oh
our son was a medical student so we went
and dug up some bones from the local
black cemetery because I guess that's a
cool thing you do whatever because it's
like oh and he was studying biology and
he wanted absconds yeah cuz you know
well yeah that's the thing that's what
they said but then when they tested the
bones they said no this is a white woman
Roy with one leg shorter than the other
so initially they thought it was
Virginia carpenter but then the dental
records didn't match so it wasn't her so
isn't that weird though have they found
like another skeleton I don't even I
don't even know if they ever determined
who that skeleton was but it wasn't any
murders but it wasn't her so the case is
unsolved now I should note that in 1998
police received an anonymous tip that oh
there were two guys and they raped and
murdered Virginia and they buried her
near a dam like that was right near the
college campus from which she
disappeared now police did investigate
this lead they dug up all the area
around the dam but they didn't find
anything and they said now both of the
people they did you know not in the
media but this person did name to the
police who the suspects were but both of
them were dead right so there was no way
they could check up on that's a problem
with cases this old you're never gonna
find these people there all right and
that's the problem and that's kind of
the sad thing and like I said it's
something that's kind of its kind of
bothering a little bit as I'm
researching all these cases is that next
of kin find out who did this right
they're probably dead by now or live
there like in their 70s or 80s just like
the Golden State killer right it's like
how much justice can be served
by you know he's lived his whole life a
free man and it's the same kind of thing
and they did actually reopen a lot of
the investigations but they had to close
them because pretty much everybody was
dead everybody dead all the suspects
were dead the plaintiffs and it's like
they're never going to send us all bit
descendants in row
so it's kind of a shame and it's kind of
the same thing that happened you know
with the Virginia carpenter case time
conquers all
yeah and with the Phantom killer case
it's like you know at this stage are
they ever going to solve it because most
of the people involved are dead and
that's pretty sad but anyway we've gone
on and on like we usually do
yeah but now we've reached the end of
the show I hope you guys enjoyed our
kind of ramshackle discussion remember
if you liked the show to like share and
subscribe with all your friends share on
all your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show please go
to our patreon which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast or go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation that
would be very much appreciated also
remember to check out our azazel store
at zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock and there
are shirts and a tote bag there that you
can purchase if you wish and also check
out our latest movie review which was
tourist trap if you haven't seen it and
that will do it for episode 95 about the
phantom killer we will see you next time
bye
[Music]
and the club close there
but their fans
and more exams would soon meet there
pretty
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you